[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Welcome, Anthony
Myint and Karen Leibowitz,
who are husband and wife
co-founders of the Perennial.
This is an award-winning San
Francisco restaurant and bar
dedicated to making
food the delicious
solution to climate change.
And when I say
award-winning, I mean Best
New Restaurants in America,
25 Most Daring Companies
in America, Best
Bars in America,
Best Cocktails in
Francisco, Most Sustainable.
And they've been awarded from
places like Bon Apetit, Food
and Wine, San Francisco
Magazine, 20 Most Important
Restaurants in America,
and a Michelin Star.
Pretty big deal.
So let me tell you a
little bit more about them.
Anthony and Karen coauthored
the memoir cookbook
Mission Street Food, Recipes
and Ideas from an Improbable
Restaurant back in 2011.
They often work together, though
Anthony is primarily
a restaurateur
whose projects include Mission
Chinese Food, Commonwealth,
and Mission Cantina.
And Karen is primarily
a food writer
who has written for Lucky
Peach, Food and Wine,
and The New York Times
among other publications.
She's also, though, co-author
with Dominique Crenn
of Autelier Crenn of
"Metamorphosis of Taste."
She's the Director
of Communications
for the Perennial,
and although Anthony
doesn't have an
official title, he's
responsible for dreaming up
all the weird environmental
projects.
I'm going to let
them get started.
Welcome.
[APPLAUSE]
KAREN LEIBOWITZ:
Well, thanks so much.
Thanks for having us.
I am Karen Leibowitz.
This is Anthony Myint.
The other title we've
come up with for him
is Problem Solver,
Problem Creator.
So the Perennial is unusual in
the restaurant world in that
it's very mission-driven.
We see it as an opportunity
to engage people
in the idea of
transforming the food
system through a kind
of environmentalism
without compromise.
So here are some pictures
of the Perennial.
The bread, which actually
we brought for you today,
which is made from
a perennial grain.
So we'll talk more about
why that's important,
but basically it's part of our
larger project of combating
climate change through food.
There's our bar, and
cocktails, and beef tartar.
And we'll talk about
why meat is actually not
off the menu at the Perennial.
ANTHONY MYINT: So
I think quickly
we'll just do a background.
Thanks for the
introduction, Julia.
And just to clarify one thing,
because sometimes restaurants
are touchy about
accolades and things--
so we helped open a restaurant
called Commonwealth,
and Commonwealth
has a Michelin Star.
So not the Perennial,
though we're hoping someday.
So we have somewhat
humble origins
in the restaurant industry,
which as Julia mentioned
are kind of documented in
this book Mission Street Food.
And so it was in 2008 when we
basically kind of got started,
and if you think
back to that time,
there were not really
gourmet food trucks or pop-up
restaurants.
It was the recession
and people were
looking for interesting dining
experience kind of on a budget.
And Twitter had just
opened, or started,
but we didn't really use
Twitter or understand
any of that stuff.
And we sublet a Guatemalan
snack cart on a Thursday night,
and then basically tried to
serve gourmet tacos from it.
And we never really thought
that that would be successful.
We just were doing
it kind of for fun.
The internet being as such,
things kind of snowballed
and a friend of ours
wrote a blog about it,
and then a local
food press eater
dot com wrote a story about it.
I think the headline called
me a high-falutin line cook.
And so I was standing on
the street corner waiting
for the truck to
show up, and I had
a cooler with a bunch of mise
en place and different stuff,
and there was another guy
standing on the corner
also looking at his phone.
And I asked him, hey, are
you here for something?
And he said, yeah, I'm
here for the food truck.
And so we had people
waiting for the truck
before I had even set foot in
the truck for the first time.
And then Karen was rushing back.
She was a grad student
in Berkeley at the time,
and ran back, and we
were scrambling around
and didn't really know
what we were doing.
And so we did that for a
few weeks and then moved
into basically a crappy
hole-in-the-wall Chinese
restaurant, which is now the
home of Mission Chinese Food.
And we did pop-up events
once a week at first,
and then eventually
twice a week.
And we invited guest
chefs and line cooks
from around the city to
come do half the menu,
and we did the other half.
And again, we never
really expected
it to last for very long
or be leading to anything.
And so we gave all the
profits away to charity,
and that was a fun way
to be part of a bigger
San Francisco community.
And so eventually, we kind
of decided, why are we
making things really hard and
serving Mexi-Chinian food one
night, and a whole-hog
dinner, and using
the wok with charcoal in it,
and grilling octopus and stuff.
Why don't we just
use the woks as woks?
And so we worked with
someone who was a guest chef,
a Korean adoptee
from Oklahoma named
Danny Bowen, who at the time
I think was a line cook.
KAREN LEIBOWITZ:
Only wearing shorts.
ANTHONY MYINT: Swim
trunks, I think, every day.
And so we started
Mission Chinese,
and we decided at some point--
or went from the
get-go with that one.
Let's not rotate the
charities all the time.
Let's just give $0.75 from
each entree to the food bank.
It was a kind of
random-seeming project
that, again, I don't think
that we necessarily thought,
we'll been doing this forever.
And then eventually it
became really successful.
Danny moved to New York
and also opened there.
When he opened in New
York, the restaurant
won New York Times Restaurant
of the Year in 2012,
despite being located inside
of a Thai takeout counter.
And since then, we've
raised over a million meals
for the San Francisco food bank.
And so I think this
speaks towards kind
of the possibilities
in the restaurant
industry of finding a project
that resonates with the public.
KAREN LEIBOWITZ: Yeah.
So the same summer that we
opened Mission Chinese Food--
2010-- we also worked with some
former coworkers of Anthony's
to open a restaurant
called Commonwealth,
which was more of the
fine-dining version of this.
But I think in
both cases, we were
interested in seeing how
food and restaurants can
be used to convey meaning.
So we were creating a kind
of link with the food bank,
and asking people to think
more about food broadly.
Not just why it was
delicious, though it
should be delicious, but also
sort of what food means to us.
And as a way to
make connections.
So from there, we wrote the
book, Mission Street Food,
and talked about that journey,
and even gave a Google Talk.
And then in 2012 we had
a baby, who is now a kid.
But I feel like that
really focused us
on issues of the future, and
thinking about especially
climate change, and we
were dismayed to learn
that by some accounts
the food system is
responsible for up to
50% of the greenhouse gas
emissions in the world.
And as people
working with food, we
felt like, what
can we do better?
And so we started trying to
improve operations at Mission
Chinese and Commonwealth.
But we started to think, what
would happen if you really
started a restaurant with the
idea of climate change in mind?
And that's where
the Perennial began.
ANTHONY MYINT: Yeah.
So as Karen mentioned, I feel
like as we were researching,
it just seemed
completely undeniable
that food is a really big
part of climate change.
And I think something that we
realized also along the way
is that the restaurant
sector is almost as
big as the entire
agriculture sector.
And there was a lot of
potential to, again,
use the restaurant sector to
try to change the food system.
You can kind of see
on this line graph--
or first, I should
say we don't get
into any of this kind of
stuff at the Perennial.
This is just for
this kind of talk.
So there's a line
chart here that
shows atmospheric
greenhouse gases,
and of course there's other
things-- industrialisation--
going on.
You can see really
big inflection points
around the invention
of the plough
and the advent of
chemical fertilizer.
This is an image
from the Dust Bowl.
I think, even as
food professionals,
we really several
years ago could not
have told you what
constitutes good farming.
We understood
organic and local--
these are important things--
but I don't think we
actually understand farming.
And I think that
kind of makes sense.
A lot of us have grown
up in a generation
of industrial agriculture and
pretty disconnected from food.
In this era, there
was also fake news.
I guess that's sort of
pertinent these days.
And the railroad
companies had a pitch
like, the ploughs
follow the rain.
And people rushed out
west to claim land,
dug up perennial
grasses that used
to live in these ecosystems,
and then started crop farming.
They eventually realized
you can't do that.
The environment is too dry.
If there's no rain six
months of the year,
this doesn't make sense.
This led to what is
called the Dust Bowl.
Dust from Oklahoma is flying
through the air and landing
in Washington, D.C.
And it kind of
had to go that far
before the government created
an agency to work on soil.
So on the one hand,
that is pretty negative,
but on the other hand it
speaks towards the potential
to radically change
the whole food system
and farming really
quickly in response
to that kind of problem.
KAREN LEIBOWITZ: So again,
this is not actually
what we talk about at
the Perennial at all
because we got into the project
with a kind of, I think,
normal standard orientation
to environmentalism
that it's all
about conservation,
or doing less bad.
But as we got into it what
we discovered was actually,
agriculture has the
capacity to really repair
the damage of climate
change because plants
draw down CO2 and can
store carbon in the soil.
And so we started to really
think about the power,
especially of perennial
plants, to restore the soil
and reverse climate change.
And so we were really
excited because it
felt like we had this
optimistic message,
and it's not just do less,
like eat less, do whatever,
but really a message
of positive action.
So that was exciting for us,
and through that research
we discovered that there
are all these new efforts
to make perennials really part
of the climate change solution.
So here's an example
of a plant that's
just recently been released and
approved for human consumption.
It's called Kernza.
It was developed by the
Land Institute in Kansas,
and you can see on
the top there is wheat
and on the bottom
there is Kernza.
And Anthony can't even reach
all the way to the end of it.
This is--
AUDIENCE: Can you bring
it a little more forward?
KAREN LEIBOWITZ: I think
a little more down, too.
So you can see that the roots
are not only longer, but also
thicker and more complex.
And they become the environment
for all sorts of life--
and microorganisms
and worms that
also are working on making the
soil more of a carbon sink.
So that's the grain that
we're using in the bread
that you're eating.
Let's just drop it.
ANTHONY MYINT: OK.
KAREN LEIBOWITZ: And that has
been an exciting thing for us.
We're the first restaurant to
be making our bread from Kernza.
It's not 100%
Kernza-- it's a mix--
but it--
ANTHONY MYINT: So
the Land Institute
has been naturally breeding
this grain for the last 15 years
in conjunction with the
University of Minnesota,
and it represents basically a
radical shift in agriculture
back to perennial polycultures.
And so, again, with the
Dust Bowl and stuff,
the prairies used to be covered
with plants like Kernza--
perennial grasses that
evolved in that ecosystem.
We plowed it up to
plants like wheat,
which you can see
on the poster, just
have much smaller root systems.
All the root systems
represent themselves--
you know, carbon in
the atmosphere that
can be back in the soil.
And as Karen mentioned, also a
whole ecosystem of microbiology
called the resosphere
that surrounds the roots.
And so the Land Institute
embarked on this journey
to basically take
agriculture back
to that kind of working
with natural systems,
instead of working
with fertilizer
and extracting from the soil.
And so Kernza is a hybrid
between perennial wheat grass
and wheat, and it's basically
in version 1.0. now.
So you can get it at
the Perennial as bread.
It's also available
commercially on the West Coast
at Whole Foods as beer
called Long Route Ale.
And that was pioneered by the
company Patagonia in their food
line Patagonia Provisions.
KAREN LEIBOWITZ: You can
see there's meat there.
I think that there is a
kind of prevailing belief
that meat is the
worst thing that you
can do for the environment.
One of the things
that we learned
is there are ways of
managing animals that
promote perennial
grasses and can actually
be climate beneficial.
So I'm going to show
you a little video.
It's very short.
We made this for an event
at the Asian Art Museum.
KAREN LEIBOWITZ: So
at the Perennial,
we've been serving
meat from a ranch that
follows this protocol.
It's called Stemple Creek.
And we've also been purchasing
the animal in large cuts
so that we find a place
for all the parts.
And so we have a
dining room and a bar,
and we can have
different kinds of cuts
for different applications.
And also trying to
think about meat
as not the centerpiece
of the meal.
So all of those together.
And I think one of the
things is that putting
such a focus on soil,
and the capacity for soil
to be a carbon sink, means that
we also are recognizing that it
doesn't make sense
to, for example,
grow herbs in soil, which are
never going to really rebuild
the soil.
So we have another
project where we're
taking food waste from the
Perennial and using it to power
a greenhouse, which is just
right across the bridge
in Oakland and kind of
frees up land for more
perennial kinds of crops.
But just to walk
you through it--
and I should mention that
the illustration on the left
was by the local artist
Wendy McNaughton,
and the one on the right
is by John Adams who also
who worked with
us on that video.
So we take the food scraps--
I mean, even if you're really
conscientious about food waste,
there's still certain
things like onion peels,
and that goes to
our worm bin, worms
are fed to fish, the fish
fertilize water, which
is used partly to
irrigate our raised beds,
but also in a system,
which is like hydroponics
but instead of using chemical
fertilizer the nutrition is
coming from
essentially fish poop.
And then so we can grow kind of
specialty herbs and lettuces,
which are then served
at the Perennial.
ANTHONY MYINT: One
thing that really
got us excited
about aquaponics was
learning about a
facility in Minneapolis
that is in the former
Hamm's Brewing Company.
And so it's a
six-level facility,
and they're producing
on one level
kind of using all the
plumbing from the brewery that
was preexisting and
they're doing aquaponics.
And as demand for the
products increase,
they project that they
will be able to produce
700,000 pounds of lettuce
and 150,000 pounds of fish
per year.
So that completely
blew my mind, and I
think that we also
read some stats where
at the end of World
War II, something
like 40% of the
produce in America
was grown in people's gardens.
It was called a Victory Garden.
And so, as Karen
mentioned, it just
seems insane to be growing
herbs and lettuces in the field
and then throwing it in
a clam-shell container
and shipping it across the
country when you could just
be growing that
in the city and it
would be fresher and a way
to use food waste in places
that don't compost.
I think one thing that
we hadn't completely
understood before this project
was the ways in which soil
health interacted
with nutrition,
and the ways in which there's
a lot of externalities
in the food system,
and you're kind
of paying for government
subsidies and different things.
This is just a little
snippet from a book that
shows some of the
nutrient differences
between a USDA-approved
egg and a pastured egg
from a well-known farm
called Polyface in Virginia.
And some of the differences
are really surprising,
and it's an orders of
magnitude difference
in terms of nutrient intensity.
And the book goes on to kind
of mention that a USDA-approved
egg doesn't have anything to
do with growing practices,
nutrition--
literally anything.
The only thing is the
size is the right size
and that it's not broken.
So it could be covered with
salmonella or whatever--
the USA doesn't care.
Meanwhile, Polyface Farms can't
even sell at a grocery store
because it's not big enough
to qualify for the USDA stuff.
So these are some
of the challenges
to small farmers and things
that, again, we don't really
want to talk about
at the dinner table,
but lead to some of the
problems in the food system.
And in a lot of
ways, climate change
is a good way to rally people
to support good farming.
So then really quick,
also about nutrition,
there's a prevailing notion
that the human body is absorbing
nutrients primarily driven
by how microbiology interacts
with and breaks down
food in the gut.
And you can't just eat
a bunch of vitamins.
You need to eat food
that has nutrients
and then the
microbiology in your gut
kind of makes it
bioavailable to you.
And then something
that also completely
surprised us, although
it makes perfect sense,
is that plant
roots are basically
like an inverted gut serving as
a home for all the microbiology
that break down the
nutrients in the soil
and then provide
that to the plant
and make the plant healthy.
So you can see there's some
little stats about how there
is significantly lower nutrient
density in a lot of food
in the US as a result
of degraded soil.
We're specifically
facing every day and sort
of dealing with consumers and
talking about these issues,
but trying to find
a way to do it
that takes two seconds
instead of 30 minutes
because no one wants to hear
this talk at the dinner table
or anything like that.
And I feel like,
even for us, prior
to getting into this project--
there's a picture here of
farmers market tomatoes,
organic tomatoes
at the supermarket,
and conventional tomatoes.
And it's sort of like, I
really had no idea what
the difference was.
If someone asked me
to articulate it,
I would have a hard
time articulating it.
And certified organic
can mean the farmer's
doing really great
stuff, or it can
mean they're just not
using things that are not
approved on the approved list.
And so in a way
it's sort of like,
there's actually
a whole lot more
to farming that is
basically beyond organic,
but how do we educate
people about this topic
or even really understand it?
And so one thing that the
restaurant is embarking on
as kind of a project
in conjunction
with a lot of different
sustainable food organizations
is making a little guide,
kind of the equivalent
of the Monterey Bay
Seafood Guide, maybe.
And apparently there's a metric
that farmers measure called
soil organic matter, and it's
just part of the basic soil
test, like pH, nitrogen,
and phosphorus levels,
and then they just have a
percent soil organic matter.
And so we're trying to work
with a lot of farmers and chefs
to make this a bigger movement
to recognize healthy soil,
using that as a proxy for
a lot of good practices.
And so it's a little bit
of an oversimplification
because it varies a little
bit from region to region.
You could also be
a great farmer who
just took over degraded
land and you're bringing it
up for different things.
But in a lot of
ways, those are sort
of the exceptions to the
rule and in a broader
way we're hoping that
this can kind of steer
the conversation in the
right direction of a focus
towards healthy soil.
KAREN LEIBOWITZ: So
just to bring it back,
we are also running a restaurant
and not generally giving
a slide show at the restaurant.
And what we really
want is for the food
to be a kind of entry
point to these discussions,
and the space to be a
place for conversation.
And the way we've
done it is really
to try to be relatively
low-key about it
and let people's questions
guide the conversation.
And we also think that if
it's not delicious, then
no one will follow suit.
So that is still a very
serious project as well.
So all in all, our
life work is really
to think about food,
which is one of the things
that every one of
us has in common,
as a way to connect
with something
bigger than ourselves.
And even creating a better
world for the future.
So there's a lot of
different projects
that we're happy to talk
about in the question period.
think These are
some books, also,
that we have found influential
for our thinking about it
and that we recommend.
But that's our spiel.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER: So I have a couple
of questions for you guys,
and I know these guys will
have some questions as well.
Why a restaurant as
your form of activism?
Why not run for Congress?
KAREN LEIBOWITZ: Well,
don't put it past us.
SPEAKER: You heard
it here first.
KAREN LEIBOWITZ: One thing is we
have experience in restaurants,
and we felt like
that was something
that drew on our expertise.
So once you sort of get the
passion for environmentalism,
it makes sense to sort
of start where you are.
And I think many different
fields could do that,
but I think food is
particularly situated
for that because of
the impact that food
has on the environment
and the capacity
to reverse climate change.
But then the last piece is,
restaurants are interestingly
influential in our culture.
If
You think about
when you were kids,
there was almost certainly
not an organic section
in your supermarket.
And the reason that we
have it can pretty much
be traced back to Chez Panisse.
That one restaurant
started talking
about where the food
came from, and it really
did change the
conversation around food.
And now Wal-Mart is
stocking organic.
ANTHONY MYINT: Sure.
I think also the way that
information travels now,
and trends move in
the food industry--
the chef of the best restaurant
in the world is foraging
in 2010, and in 2011 we're
foraging in San Francisco,
and in 2012 we're
already over-foraging--
and so I think it
would be really
exciting to be part of that
movement in the restaurant
industry, too, and
that it's possible.
SPEAKER: You guys are
trendsetters, for sure.
So follow-up
questions with that.
You said that your activism
is subtle in the restaurant.
It's not something that you're
beating people over their heads
with.
Can you share a little
bit more about what
that experience might be like
when you visit the restaurant?
And also-- double question--
what kind of clientele
are you attracting?
Do you feel like you're ever
kind of preaching to the choir?
Are you hoping to reach
out to more than just
the people in the know?
KAREN LEIBOWITZ: Well,
second question first.
I think there's a
really wide range.
So I was talking
with a server who
said that he often will be
delivering the third course
and someone will say,
is there a theme here?
Because he's just sort of
let them have their date
or whatever, and really tried
not to impose the message.
And other people come
in and they're like,
I have seven questions.
Should we do them
before I order or after?
They're really engaged.
And so our goal is
to be kind of useful
and move the conversation
for all of those people.
And actually,
excitingly, lately we've
had an influx of
people who are going
to see Hamilton around the
corner from the restaurant.
And so they might not
have as much time,
because they've got
to make the curtain,
but it's a whole range of
people who are not necessarily
coming for the
environmentalism, but it becomes
part of the whole experience.
It's a night out where all
kinds of synapses are firing.
ANTHONY MYINT: I
think also we've
started to gain a reputation
in the sustainable food
movement as a gathering place,
and so we have a lot of events.
I was talking to people who were
working on a food waste dinner,
and we were talking, I
was making the rounds,
and then they were
looking behind them
and they were like, I think
that's our cricket farmer.
It sort of feels a
little bit like the bar
across from City Hall where the
lawyers go and make the deals.
And so it's kind of
fun to be part of that,
too, just in a physical way.
KAREN LEIBOWITZ: Yeah.
Speaking of the bar,
I think that can
be one way to engage with it.
The straws that we use
are not made from plastic.
They're made from straw.
And so people at first
are sort of like,
this is not what I'm used
to, and will really have
a lot of questions about it.
And the bartenders
are like, yeah,
you can have seven of them if
you want because they're all
compostable.
It's totally natural.
And actually, plastic
straws are incredibly
wasteful in most bars.
The bartenders use a couple
to stir and test and then
throw them away.
And we have none of that.
And so some of that stuff,
you just sort of like--
it's like chatting with
the bartender, you know?
SPEAKER: Awesome.
So the salon for sustainability
is the hope, which I like that.
A couple more
questions for you guys.
I'm sure you're hoping
that the Perennial can be
a model for other restaurants.
Do you know any
other restaurants
that are doing similar work?
How do you partner
with them if so?
ANTHONY MYINT: Well, there
are two really great examples.
One is a restaurant in
upstate New York called
Blue Hill at Stone Barns.
And the chef there probably
is, more than anyone,
responsible for kind of
spearheading what you
might call farm-to-table 2.0.
And he's working
with the breeders
to basically breed heirloom
varieties of wheat,
or breed a cross of squash that
is more flavorful, or whatever.
So kind of doing more
than chopping, for sure.
And then the other
is a restaurant
in Brighton in the
UK called Silo,
and they're a
no-waste restaurant.
Zero waste.
And so they have Big Bertha--
their composter is
front and center.
And they're growing mushrooms
from the coffee grounds.
If the purveyors bring
produce in plastic bags,
then there's a local artisan
who melts them down and makes
plates with them,
and different stuff.
And so we really admire
all these efforts
that everyone's doing.
We happen to be located
in the middle of the city,
so I think what
Dan Barber is doing
at Blue Hill is
not available to us
because they're
located on a farm.
And then at Silo, I feel
like zero waste is amazing
and we're trying to just
focus on climate change.
KAREN LEIBOWITZ: Yeah, but
in terms of partnering,
we definitely talk with
them and share ideas.
And that is something
that's really fun
that, when you have a
mission-driven business,
there's more of a
collaborative orientation.
So we chat with the
folks from Silo.
The people from Blue
Hill at Stone Barns
had a book party
with us last week.
There's sort of a sense
of a movement, which
I think we're at
the beginning of,
but it's exciting to kind
of make those connections.
SPEAKER: Absolutely.
Speaking of movements,
I know we're all looking
for farm-to-table 2.0--
like, the new name.
Because we might be over
that particular name.
We might be saying
that too much.
So if you've got a good
idea for us, let us know.
I have one last
question and then
I'm going to open
it up to these guys.
The parent in me
really wants to know,
do you have a picky eater?
KAREN LEIBOWITZ: Yes and no.
We have an almost
five-year-old who eats
vegetables that are not leaves.
So broccoli, string beans--
ANTHONY MYINT: She
eats lettuce now.
KAREN LEIBOWITZ: Sometimes.
Yeah.
ANTHONY MYINT: But she
definitely probably
prefers plain pasta, too.
Pasta with herb sauce.
KAREN LEIBOWITZ: Yeah.
I had a moment with her
in a grocery store where
she went to the
cheese counter and she
said, "I'm looking for some
fancy cheese with no flavor."
And I was like, that
is very accurate.
That is what she wants.
SPEAKER: Do you feel like your
five-year-old is growing up
knowing words like
sustainability, and organic,
and local, and things like that?
Is this the new generation?
KAREN LEIBOWITZ: Well,
she just recently
learned about global warming.
ANTHONY MYINT: From a kids book.
KAREN LEIBOWITZ:
From a kids book.
I had been trying to
protect her from that,
but we talk a lot about
the work that worms do,
and we try to get
her into gardening
and seeing the kind of power
and excitement of making food,
growing it, cooking it,
serving it-- all of it.
Actually, giving it away.
Going to food pantries
and things like that.
She's definitely
food-oriented, for sure,
but she also has ideas
about global warming.
She asked me if she could throw
ice cubes out the back door.
She was like, "I'm
trying to cool it down!"
So that was hard to explain.
SPEAKER: I love that.
So you guys are pioneers and
superheroes, which I love.
I'm going to open it up to
these guys for questions.
So in case you can't hear,
are some of the events
that you talked about public?
And if so, how do
we get involved?
KAREN LEIBOWITZ: For sure.
Well, we have an Earth
Day celebration coming up.
And we do probably once or
twice a month public events.
You can follow us
on social media,
and we have a newsletter also.
Actually, do want to
explain the Earth Day plan?
ANTHONY MYINT: Sure.
So we're lucky enough
to have met someone
who works at the San Francisco
Department of the Environment
named Donnie Olivera.
And so he's going to come and
talk about the city's plans,
which are completely amazing.
I don't know if I'm allowed
to say the specifics,
but the city has a goal
of zero waste by 2020.
KAREN LEIBOWITZ: The
clock is ticking!
ANTHONY MYINT: 50% of trips--
50% of passenger trips
not made by cars, and then
100% renewable energy.
So you can hear more
details about those,
and drink beer made
from Kernza, and I
think he has promised-- though
I'm waiting for confirmation--
but he's promised
that he'll be bringing
his bike-powered
margarita setup.
KAREN LEIBOWITZ: Yeah.
And then we're also doing--
we're sort of starting
a series of events
with winemakers because we have
kind of incredible winemakers
nearby, who many
of them are really
engaging with sustainable
agricultural practices.
The first wine-tasting that
we're doing with a winemaker
is on say March 25th, and then
we're doing also a week later,
you can just hang out in the
bar and drink wine and chat
with him.
He'll just be around
to talk about,
what difference does it make
if your wine cellar is actually
a cellar, or if
it's above ground?
There's actually a huge
difference in the energy use.
Things like that.
So sort of at different
levels of dorkiness.
Actually, Anthony mentioned
the City of San Francisco guy.
But he did not mention the
bike-powered margaritas.
So getting that slushy
margarita with your own bike
power for Earth Day.
And I think Mother Jones is
having a party on April 12th.
I will need to
check on that date,
but their food team is going to
have a public event in our bar.
So I'm excited for that.
SPEAKER: Tell us more
about zero food print.
ANTHONY MYINT: Sure.
So zero food print actually
predated the Perennial.
I was part of starting
that with a friend named
Chris Ying and an environmental
expert named Peter Fried.
And Chris Ying used to be the
editor of Lucky Peach Magazine.
And I think the
goal was basically
to learn about how restaurants
are part of climate change.
And I think it started with
an initial question like,
are restaurants really bad?
How does it compare
to a home-cooked meal?
So they did a
life-cycle analysis
and kind of learned
that it's not that bad.
Pretty comparable to
a home-cooked meal
for various reasons.
And then from there
sort of realized
that restaurants can
make small changes that
make a big difference.
Most people are kind of too
focused on the day-to-day like,
is my dishwasher going
to show up today?
Or is my meat order
going to come?
Or whatever.
But then over the
course of it, I
think we learned a
lot of things like,
the carbon footprint
of feed lot beef
is so high that
serving fried chicken
instead could be an
environmental act.
Or just different ways
I think a lot of people
understand things like the
amount of calories in butter
versus celery, but
a lot of people
don't really understand the
carbon footprint of cheese
versus tomatoes is also
orders of magnitude different.
And chefs and
restaurateurs, especially.
So I think part of that was
to kind of educate chefs
and restaurateurs, to let
them make the changes that
were easy to make
and then give them
a way to participate in a
food-related carbon offset
program.
So a small share of a methane
digester on a dairy farm
because a restaurant
is ultimately
going to have some carbon
footprint because they're
serving food and doing stuff.
But then they can kind of
facilitate positive work
somewhere else in
the food system.
And then basically qualify as
being zero food print or carbon
neutral.
So in a lot of ways,
that's a top-down approach
that any restaurant can adopt.
KAREN LEIBOWITZ:
But just to clarify
that kind of relationship
among our projects--
we have the Perennial,
which is a restaurant that's
really dedicated to the idea
that food can be regenerative,
right?
So one of the terms that we use
instead of farm-to-table 2.0
is regenerative agriculture.
But we have the restaurant
that's sort of consumer-facing.
And then we have
a nonprofit called
Zero Food Print, which is
really chef-facing and saying,
here's how to assess
your footprint,
improve your footprint,
and offset your footprint.
And then we have another
nonprofit as well,
which is farm-facing,
which is about sharing
information about soil
health, and best practices,
and things like that.
And so the whole
suite of activities
is really about
saying, hey, there's
only one thing that
we know right now that
can draw down greenhouse gases.
Let's get on that.
And so wherever
you are, wherever
you are within the food system,
here's how you can engage.
SPEAKER: What kind
of adoption have
you had with Zero Food Print?
ANTHONY MYINT: So
this past year we
have started working with
about 20 restaurants.
We would gladly welcome
any sort of larger
institutional partnerships.
At a larger
institutional level--
Google, for example,
probably has a Director
of Sustainability and they could
probably do their own research
and find their own offsets
or buy a whole digester
as their own program.
They wouldn't necessarily need
a slice of a pie of a project
that someone else
is funding entirely,
but we would love to work
with any organizations that
would want to work with us.
KAREN LEIBOWITZ: Yeah.
So Zero Food Print has
been expanding and working
with restaurant groups,
which is interesting
because you can sort of compare
and contrast with a group.
But we're really interested
also in getting into groceries
and thinking about
all the different ways
that people access food.
Yeah.
And there is someone
who we've worked with,
kind of consulting on
food and carbon footprint
data, this author who wrote
one of the books on the screen,
"How Bad Are Bananas?"
And it's basically like
the carbon footprint
of a dozen eggs, or an
email, or your mortgage,
or driving across town.
And he has done
a whole lifecycle
analysis, or assessment,
for a UK groceries
chain called Tesco.
And so one of their
stories is carbon neutral.
SPEAKER: Krista's
excellent question
was, where do we get
more of the good stuff?
The Kernza.
KAREN LEIBOWITZ: Yeah.
I think the Land Institute is
rapidly expanding production,
but it is really
early days for Kernza.
AUDIENCE: Is that
where yours comes from?
From Kansas or--
ANTHONY MYINT: So
there's farmers
growing Kernza in Illinois,
Kansas, and Minnesota.
Kind of like the
grain belt. And so it
sort of wants winter
vernalization period
to grow best, and since it's
kind of in the ramping-up up
stage it makes the most
sense to grow it in the place
where it grows best.
I should also say we don't
100% know all the answers
because they're
kind of changing,
but our understanding
most recently
is that the way that it
integrates with machinery
for processing and milling and
stuff, it is most like spelt.
And they use a spelt dehuller,
but sometimes there's
a little bit of hull left on it.
And so that is a
little bit labor
intensive to get it perfect
for bread-making and stuff.
So it's going to be commercially
available as flour in 2019,
and it's available
as beer immediately
because you can make
beer even if there's
a little bit of hull.
So that's a widespread
commercial project,
and they anticipate
based on kind
of the arc of how the
natural breeding is
going, that they'll
be ready with flour
in a couple of years.
And so it is pretty early,
but by the same token
a week or two ago General
Mills signed a deal with--
or I don't know if that's
the right term, but is--
KAREN LEIBOWITZ: Committed.
ANTHONY MYINT: Yeah.
Committed to
support the project.
And so I don't know
the specifics of that,
but I think it
involves guaranteeing
farmers contracts to
start incorporating it
into the Cascadian
Farms line or whatever,
if that is of General
Mills, and then
also a $500,000 grant to
the University of Minnesota
to continue research on it.
So again, this is happening
now, or available now or soon,
and then 10 or 20
years from now they
expect to also be
providing perennial wheat.
And people in China are
working on perennial rice,
and so I feel like
it's the very beginning
of the shift of agriculture
back to natural systems.
SPEAKER: I guess I would
sum that question up as,
tell us more about
what you are doing
to get mainstream adoption.
And are you limited by things
like scale in the restaurant?
ANTHONY MYINT: So we are working
with this ranch, Stemple Creek
Ranch, in part
because they are one
of the pilot ranches with an
organization called the Marine
Carbon Project.
And so we're really lucky to
have kind of stumbled onto it
because they just are
an hour from here.
And we visited the ranch,
and when we got there one
of the founders was
sitting in a parking lot--
a windy parking lot
at the top of a hill--
with a white board talking
to inspectors from the United
Nations.
And kind of starting the
process of making carbon
farming a recognized federal
subsidized type of activity.
Like, measuring the
amount of carbon
and then starting
to divert money
to subsidize that
kind of farming.
And so there's actually many
different ranches in our area
that are working
on carbon ranching.
Tomcat Ranch and their
beef brand, which is called
Left Coast Grass Fed.
There's one called
Holistic Ag Beef.
And [INAUDIBLE] Ranch
and True Grass Farm.
So there's a lot
of different people
who are independently
doing carbon farming.
And there are people in
South Dakota, Montana,
and all over the US who are kind
of doing it just because it's
a better yield anyway.
So it just makes sense anyway.
The breakthrough for the
Marine Carbon Project
is that they apply compost to
the field at the beginning,
and that sort of
jump-starts the process.
And also, contrary to what
scientists would expect,
actually leads to
durable soil carbon
that will last for
30 to 100 years,
or continue to be sequestered
for 30 to 100 years
just from one application and
then properly managed grazing.
So in a lot of ways, that
is even more surprising
how fast and optimistic
the message is.
So the Marine Carbon Project
has three pilot branches now,
and it's going to be 20
within a couple of years.
And their work is basically
to work with ranchers
and create specific plans
for that ranch that's like,
plant trees here, do this
for this part of the ranch,
divert the pond here so
you can irrigate whatever.
And the whole thing
has a certain amount
of scientific rigor and
peer-reviewed carbon
sequestration assigned to
each action for each area.
And then they can take that
carbon farm plan of like,
we're going to sequester 10,000
tons over whatever time period
to the government and
get money to start
implementing that plan.
So I think it will
be scaling up.
KAREN LEIBOWITZ: And
you know, California
has been working on how to apply
the carbon tax that we've had.
So there's the question of
how to reward people who
are doing this kind of work.
And so we've been a
little bit involved
in lobbying Sacramento for a
healthy soil initiative to say,
people in the city also care
about agricultural issues.
So I think all in all, we
feel that it is very scalable.
And we're sort of coming at it
from the direction of building
consumer demand, talking
to the farmers that we know
and connecting them with
resources like the Marine
Carbon Project, and
then also working
on it from a political angle.
ANTHONY MYINT: But I think
also, if you think back
to 10 years ago, I didn't
spend the extra dollars
on grass-fed beef, and
it wasn't as ubiquitous.
And now it's kind of all
over the place and people
are more used to spending
that extra dollar,
and so in a lot of ways
we're just trying to--
I hate to keep doing this, but
kind of kickstart grass-fed
2.0 where it's like, cows are
part of the climate change
solution, unless
they're feed-lot cows.
Then that's part of the problem.
KAREN LEIBOWITZ: Superbad.
SPEAKER: So I think the
question is, grass-fed beef is
more expensive.
Do you feel like the Bay
Area can sustain that?
And if not, then are
other restaurants
going to be implementing
the true cost of food
in the future?
KAREN LEIBOWITZ: Yeah.
I think your question
also is beyond the beef
itself but just like,
is sustainable food
going to work as a
sustainable business model?
And I think that is the
big experiment that we've
embarked on, and the
Bay Area obviously
is a kind of prime
place to try it out.
I think the bigger
question is, could people
do that outside of the Bay Area?
But Anthony and I
were just talking
this morning about kind of
that perception of value
in food in America.
So I had read that in 1930,
the average American household
spent 25% of its income on food.
In 1950, that c was 30%.
It had gone up.
And that it's now--
in the thing I read it was
9% and Anthony was like,
oh, I read 6.4%.
So we now are spending just
a really small fraction
of our income on food, and
it's much less actually
than other comparable nations.
And so we have ideas
about what food
costs that are based on
pretty perverse incentives.
So the way that our government
subsidizes poor agriculture
has really set us up to
believe that food is cheap
and should always be cheap.
And the ideas that we have
about how much meat costs,
in particular, is really
based on something
which is not really
defensible on any level--
ethically or environmentally,
or even health.
So I think that there
will be a big shift
and the question is,
will people start
seeing that fast enough for
us to survive as a business?
Because our ideas about
these things change
kind of generationally, not in
the span of a restaurant lease.
So we'll see.
SPEAKER: That's a really great
question to wrap it up with.
Thank you so much for your time.
We really appreciate it.
I learned a lot.
Thank you, guys.
[APPLAUSE]